thank you for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show open phones a
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Jennifer is in San Diego hi
Jennifer how are you
I'm cold thank you for taking my call I
really appreciate it sure what's up in
your work oh my goodness is just a lot a
lot of changes in the past couple years
just this last month I took a huge pay
cut and I'm going to run out of money to
pay my bills so I really need some
advice and the plan on how to even
approach all this because there's just
so much going on in my life that I don't
even order to start I mean I have a lot
of credit card debt and guys even
dramatic it's getting pretty scary isn't
it yeah I can't believe that I have the
book and I read a while ago and I know
it's all behavior late yes behavior
behavior behavior and I just I had that
false sense of security of swiping the
credit card for everything you know and
out of the blue it just looks medical
like that my daughter had them we
learned the past year and a half that
she's had some long medical conditions
so she was hospitalized quite a few
times last year and I'm therefore I
wasn't able to work on full time and my
husband had to quit his job because he's
caring for her full time I'm giving her
meds throughout the days and so now I'm
just in a position where you know I
unresponsible affect that obvious and
not provide this much pleasure what what
is your end what is your income
household now now 100 looks worth
100,000 years that's after the pay cut
that's after the peghead I was making
141 Atika what was your husband making
when he was working um he was making
probably like 35 maybe okay and how's
your daughter's health
now I'm she's a a kind of rare condition
that's progressive so I mean she's home
she
with us she's okay we don't know no
there's no cure for what she has um she
doesn't eat she two-and-a-half should be
three and may that um she's on a feeding
tube so we we feed her through formula
through tube and yes she's hospitalized
for a couple months last shift and the
last year from October to December she
got like oh they got discharged before
Christmas and um yes especially in
college I heard father have her gosh it
scares you to death how much dad have
you got oh my god this is so scary to
even mention when I pull out the numbers
it's from overwhelming
um credit cards is ridiculous I have
above $100,000 in credit card debt and
personal loans about 40 over a little
forty thousand and then I have a
mortgage
how much is your monthly payment on your
mortgage ah first mortgage is about two
thousand and second mortgage just bumped
up
oh my home I could align 25.5 fifty okay
so it's really time five dollars on that
all right and what other dad's okay
Medical Health Medical medical medical
honors I think I'm okay I've been
putting money aside and I have a an HMO
where where pain actually in my budget I
just need a budget for three to five
hundred dollars a month probably for
everything with all the medications
she's on because a lot of it's just a
lot of supplements she's on it
some of it's not covered through
insurance but she needs it okay so your
current mostly on your medical okay
so here's what I want you to do right
you've got a little baby your first
child that's ill no it's actually my
first daughter I have other children you
said your first daughter okay so you
have a little baby that you know and it
is absolutely emotionally overwhelming
for any of us okay it's okay to be
scared and freaked out and disorganize
that's a you can't stay there it's not
working for you but you know I just want
you to know that what you're going
through is like really normal normal
people would have the same reaction okay
okay so you need to sit down with your
husband tonight and you guys need to
turn off the television and put the
other kids to bed and have a discussion
that hey we're both emotional
drained by fighting the debt and
fighting this this medical situation and
it's tiring and we have to work together
on not only our daughter but we have to
work together on this money I need your
help with this I don't want you to do it
for me I want us to work together on it
say you're you and here making the
decisions together so that's step one
okay that you have because you don't
have a lot of a gas left in your
emotional tank and I don't want you to
be the last little bit out trying to
make these decisions by yourself and
what you work together okay
the second thing then is the
prioritization is going to be absolutely
vital and the prioritization sounds like
this the most important thing you do is
you take care of what we call keeping
the four walls of your house stood up
and the four walls of your house are the
necessities food is first you make
$100,000 a year you're going to have
food you're not going to eat out much
you're going to cook at home but we're
going to like you're not going to eat
out at all you don't have any money
you're broke you can't go out to eat
going out to eat some luxury okay
I'm comfortable we're going to buy food
we got the money for food and family's
not going to go hungry the second thing
is you're going to pay lights and water
and you're going to keep your utilities
on you got the money to do that the
third thing is and you're going to stop
all retirement and stop paying anything
in at work where you can bring home as
much money as you can bring home because
of your pay cut you're going to stop it
temporarily you have a crisis on your
hands so food is first lights and water
a second you pay your house payment
third food clothing transportation
shelter so you have a car payment could
we keep gas in the car and the insurance
paid on the car that's transportation
you don't probably don't need enclosed
but if you need some basic clothes a
little tiny clothing budget but not much
you're probably okay on clothes probably
where they'll make you wear the ones you
guys were what if a kids got yeah if a
kids got a you know a thing they've
outgrown or something you may have to
buy a little bit of kids clothes but we
keep the clothing budget very very slim
so here's the thing you got food you got
a place to live you got lights and water
we got clothes
we got the car running with gas in so we
can get the work or get to the doctor so
now we're okay the rest of this is a
Monopoly game and you're behind it takes
a long time yet I'm about to be behind
I've decided you're behind you have
$100,000 in credit card debt okay you
got a big mess on your hands but here's
the thing if you can keep the emotional
basics of your life under you by
prioritizing those things as first then
you're in a position emotionally to
fight through this other stuff and any
money we can squeeze out of the budget
at that point we're going to start
trying to beat these debts down you need
to cut up the credit cards you have to
stop using them yes today you need to
get them out tonight with your husband
cut up every single one of them this has
not worked for you it is a curse not a
blessing and so you have to stop it
completely cold turkey no more credit
cards we cannot buy anything unless we
pay for it from this point forward
period now you got food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities we're not
adding any more debt then the first goal
is to pay the basics and stay current
and after that any dollars we can
squeeze out of our household income any
extra income we can pick up anything
we've got that's expensive that we can
sell we start working our way through
this if your income doesn't come back up
and you can't make your minimums then
you're going to probably have to look at
selling your house because that's the
poop the corner you put yourself in so
you can give yourself a few months to
get your income up and you know make
some decisions to be able to attack this
debt and clean up a bunch of this stuff
but and I think you probably got more
room now jump on every dollar at every
dollar calm and that's a free online
budgeting tool and an app for your
iPhone and your droid your Android and
you can get to every dollar app and it
will help you guys do your budget
tonight but it'll give you a lot of
peace you'll sense the secure you'll
sense the stress dropping down as you
say okay we got the basics covered
we can cover this we can cover that we
can cover that we can't cover that one
okay so you got it all done but that one
you know and that helps y'all whole
bunch they can get your number of
enemies in the stress beat down to just
one or two and I think you can make the
corner here I think you can turn the
corner on this but I think you've just
been stressed out and freaked out and
grieving with what you've been facing I
don't blame you for that this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
Oh
[Music]